Holding a tablet that was written
thousands of years ago
and being able to read what it says
is an amazing feeling.
If you see a cuneiform tablet
for the first time
you're not likely to identify it
as writing
and you certainly wouldn't know
which way up it went.
It's a form of time travel -
it catapults you back in time,
thousands of years
and puts you directly into
the shoes of somebody
who lived so many years before us.
The earliest known form of writing
is called cuneiform.
First used over 5000 years ago
it's believed to predate
Egyptian hieroglyphs.
Cuneiform was used by civilisations
that lived in Mesopatamia.
Several societies used cuneiform
as their writing system
including the Sumerians
and the Akkadians.
Pressed onto clay, cuneiform tablets
are incredibly durable,
they're literally fireproof,
but for thousands of years,
no one was able to translate them.
After much trial and error,
cuneiform script was finally
deciphered in the Victorian era.
What they revealed was extraordinary.
Once cuneiform was deciphered
lots of unexpected things
came to light
but probably none
which had greater impact
than the discovery by George Smith
in 1872
of the 11th tablet
of the Epic of Gilgamesh
in which he encountered
for the first time, the flood story.
Finding an ancient tablet with the
story of Noah's Ark
written hundreds of years
before the Bible
shattered the Victorian's
understanding of the world.
When it arrived, it was a huge...
...bang, thing like that.
It was a very explosive matter.
And the parallel was much more
than a sort of, general similarity
with a boat and water and animals.
It was in the same order
and there were many close points that
compellingly showed
that this same story had been current
in Mesopotamia
a millennium before the earliest date
when the Hebrew text is likely to
have come into existence.
It wasn't easy
being a woman in Mesopotamia
but women in wealthy families
were treated fairly well.
The first known author
in all of recorded history
is actually a woman.
The Akkadian priestess, Enheduanna.
The case of Enheduanna shows us
that women could reach extremely high
and important positions
in Mesopotamian religion.
We learn a lot about society,
about beliefs
relations between husband and wife
business transactions going wrong.
We know from cuneiform tablets
that women had agency.
We have contracts where they are
allowed to buy houses
and they retain control
of their dowry.
They can run and manage businesses
in their own right
as long as alongside their husbands.
If you've ever wondered
why there's 60 seconds in a minute
or 360 degrees in a circle
it's because
the Sumerians and Akkadians
used a numbering system
that was sexagesimal.
Which means that they counted
on a base of 60
and divisions of 60
and multiplications by 60
where we tend to use
the decimal system.
Our own time measurement into 60
seconds in a minute
and 60 minutes in an hour
is a direct inheritance from
Mesopotamian scholarly tradition.
It's amazing how many concepts
we take for granted
in our modern society
can actually be found for the first
time in ancient Mesopotamia.
The whole concept
of mathematical models
the very idea that you can use data
to predict things happening
in the future
and that's foundational
to all modern science.
The Mesopotamians
were keen letter writers
sending sealed messages
with traders and travellers.
Reading these letters today,
you realise that in many ways,
not much has changed.
We can see that there were specific
formulae in their correspondence.
As we start an email today by
"I hope all is well"
they also started
with specific formulae.
But when they were angry
they forgot about
this formulaic convention
and they just started the letter
very matter-of-factly.
As well as writing about
stock levels,
taxes and receipts on their tablets
cuneiform writers loved to gossip.
We do have letters
from these women
complaining that the men
are not sending enough money home.
We have a certain sense
of keeping up with the Joneses
saying "next door has built
an extension to their house,
when are we going to have the money
to build an extension to our house?"
So these kind of things
really do come through
and we see
these little human concerns
these little human squabbles
desires, jealousies and so on.
By studying the past
we learn so much about ourselves
and the world that we live in.
But the secrets revealed
in cuneiform tablets
are only known to us today
because of clay's durability.
The way that we record things
is constantly evolving.
Technological progress means
things become obsolete very quickly.
The messages we send every day
are stored in the cloud.
How likely is it that anyone will be
able to read that in 20 years
let alone a few thousand years?
There is a project in Austria
which is inscribing 1000 of
the most important books of our era
onto ceramic tablets.
So humanity has really
come full circle
from writing on clay
at the very beginning of history
to writing on clay again
in a different way
to preserve our information now.
There are many initiatives trying to
prevent digital data from being lost.
Could it be that despite
all the incredible technology
we have at our fingertips
ancient methods
of recording information
are the best way
of preserving our secrets
for generations to come.